Vader immortal from ILM xlab on oculus
quest is the ultimate Star Wars
experience and if you haven't had the
force flow through you yet do there is
no try
throughout the series you will go from a
lowly smuggler with a hydro spanner to a
force wielding lightsaber swinging
destiny changer of a galaxy far far away
[Music]
did you think you could become my
apprentice
you were leads to an end but now you
have outlived your usefulness
Invader immortal episode 1 you get the
basics of movement climbing and
lightsaber fighting as well as a
definite feeling that something more is
going on here
the oculus quest touch controllers allow
you to feel the world around you as you
vault up ladders to escape storm
troopers and activate your lightsaber to
defend back to back with Darth frickin
Vader against ancient droids who are
wielding swords of their own the sound
of Vader's breath behind you is
unsettling in such immersive VR Vader
immortal episode 2 is where the oculus
touch controllers really shine urinate
Force abilities begin to emerge as Vader
teaches you how to use them for a short
time obviously to his own ends but you
don't really have time to mourn a Sith
Lord being a Sith Lord or the imminent
danger you're in because you have the
force literally in your hands now you
start learning in a game of Boulder
catch with the force artist formerly
known as Anakin and soon graduate to
impaling rancor with stalactites and
changing the fate of the galaxy itself
you know no big deal you are the
descendant of Lady corvax an ancient who
lost her love and in order to save his
life stole the bright star the power
crystal that was the heart of Mustafar
and subsequently turned the planet into
the floating ball of lava that we've
come to know from other games and movies
you discover why Vader needs your
assistance while exploring the caverns
and tunnels beneath the ruins surface
he's been obsessed with death ever since
the loss of Queen Amidala
in addition to bearing witness to the
inks that exist some of the big black
helmet you may help the mustafar Ian's
restore their planet to its former lush
green glory I say may because this is an
opposition to the Sith Lords plans this
series is canon in the Star Wars galaxy
so you'll be encountering many things
while playing it than either connect to
existing law or maybe the starting point
for new things you'll see coming out in
the future of the Star Wars saga because
these titles are made by some of the
same people that worked on the film's
they are peppered with references and
easter eggs that players of any level of
Star Wars fandom are going to get nerd
chills experiencing captain if you want
to improve your lightsaber in force
wielding you can try to master the
lightsaber dojo that throws everything
from droids to native Mustafar Ian's
lava nips at you while you throw your
lightsaber right back at them the
feeling of force pulling a droid towards
you then dropping it down a hole makes
you really know the power of the dark
side all three episodes of Vader
immortal are out now on oculus quest and
you can get all of them free with the
purchase of an oculus quest headset
until January 31st so go get one and
then beat your friends high scores in
the lightsaber dojo that training may
come in handy if you ever find yourself
facing off against a Sith Lord with a
laser sword in a galaxy far far away
thank you so much for watching and may
the force be with the droids that you
throw down holes